so far so far walking onto the grounds
of the Superhuman Center you're struck
by a wave of ambition courage and
camaraderie
Sergey kopashak is teased by the CEO of
the organization she tells him now that
he's mastered the stairs they should
discharge him he retorts saying as much
as he likes it here he'll have to leave
sometime Sergey is amazing because he
was the one who was very quick to
rehabilitate and like he started walking
on like third day the superhuman's
philosophy is not about what's been lost
but what's been added
I've been on my prosthetic for a month
now he says he admits it wasn't easy
they're not his legs but he's mastering
them and he's decorated them hoper
shook's left leg was torn off the right
one badly damaged during shelling the 25
year old Soldier smiles when he talks
about being upgraded to a cyborg those
admitted to the Superhuman Center are
initially seen by a fellow amputee the
team is explicit in its belief that
abled body people cannot grasp the loss
or the lifelong pain and struggle of
having a prosthetic which will always
require adjustments but they can help to
reshape how Society views them we
believe that if we have superhumans on
the streets of Ukraine it's going to be
different trajectory for the country and
if our kids are raised in the context of
superhumans not in the context of
victims of war we're going to have a
different country
some prosthetic pieces are made locally
at the Superhuman Center other
components are sourced from
manufacturers until the work can be done
in-house they're also building temporary
living space next door and want to add a
surgical Ward and hire their own medical
staff this facility really is meant to
be a One-Stop shop from manufacturing
downstairs to the rehabilitation in the
floor and up here people are doing
everything from exercises to even having
their Prosthetics adjusted to make
walking a little bit easier ultimately
they want to see five of these
facilities right across Ukraine
many people have complications and have
to start over as I did after surgery
says yuvhen who only gave us his first
name he just recently started to receive
Care at the Superhuman Center he says
it's more Progressive more prepared to
help people like him the facility has
some big backers including American
Howard Buffett son of Warren Buffett
who's donated more than 16 million
dollars to superhumans and just recently
visited the facility the estimated
operating cost is about one million
dollars per month Olga rudnova believes
when people see what they're doing and
why they're doing it more Partners will
come on board we are building the future
culture right here right now with these
amazing people who gave their health and
parts of their body for the victory
looking ahead to the future is
motivation for Sergey
I have a son in two months and my dream
is to meet my wife from the maternity
hospital standing on my own two feet a
dream that's getting closer step by step
day by day Crystal gemancing global news
leviv Ukraine